[Musik]
der vatikan machtzentrum der
römisch-katholischen kirche gilt dass
konservativ dass seine vertreter ein
problem haben mit männern die männer
lieben ist bekannt doch ausgerechnet der
vatikan soll eine der größten
homosexuellen communitys der welt
beherbergen
das behauptet mein heutiger gast der
französische soziologe und journalist
frederik machte er sitzen paris fest ich
hier in zürich deshalb führen wir das
interview per style gedacht einen guten
tag frederik machte wie geht es ihnen
nicht gut
zurzeit kann ich niemanden treffen
deshalb möchte ich ihnen danken dass sie
mit mir sprechen sonst wirklich total
vereinsamen
oder sie bei uns sind es gibt noch viel
zu tun ich weiß nicht ob diese
quarantäne einen monat funktioniert und
wie sie überleben aber ein paar tage ist
es kein problem
wir werden sehen kommen wir zum thema
über das wir heute sprechen wollten
sie behaupten vatikanische raten
bischöfe und kardinäle seien einerseits
schwul und lehnen andererseits
homosexualität firmen
das klingt nach einem dramatischen
szenario nicht wahr
ja und nein
wenn sie sich die tradition der kirche
anschauen können wir eigentlich von
einer kohärenz sprechen aber klar viele
leute sagt mir es sei unglaublich dass
kirchenvertreter sowohl schwul als auch
homophob sein können jedoch wenn sie
trost lesen oder android oder rambo und
das sind nur französischer autoren und
dann noch thomas mann oder ins kino ries
conti dazu nehmen
das waren aber keine privaten oder
bischöfe
nein aber die psychologie ist dieselbe
man wird extrem homophob wenn man selber
schwul ist oder homo viel
damit sind männer gemeint die ihre
homosexualität nicht ausleben aber die
neigung dazu verspüren
und wenn man angst hat dass diese
homosexualität öffentlich wird reagiert
man eben damit dass man sich homophob
gibt nun um den vatikan und die kirche
generell zu verstehen muss man verstehen
dass wir wenn wir über den vatikan
sprechen nicht über menschen sprechen
die im jahr 2020 leben viele von ihnen
leben noch immer in den 1950 er oder
60er jahren
ich habe mit vielen gesprochen die waren
über 90 jahre alt einer sogar 94
das sind männer die in den 1940 er oder
50er jahren 20 jahre alt waren als sie
in die kirche eingetreten sind
sie haben ihre welt sich und damit auch
die art wie sie homosexualität
beurteilen
vor 50 oder 60 jahren entwickelt das
erklärt alles sie leben in einer anderen
zeit ich bin ich gegen sie ich
kritisiere sie nicht ich versuche sie zu
verstehen
wir kommen noch zu diesem punkt in ihrer
hypothese steckt trotzdem eine menge
sprengkraft
lassen sie mich so beginnen ein mann der
an seiner homosexualität festhält kann
gemäss römisch katholischer lehre nicht
priester werden und trotzdem sagen sie
beziehungsweise zitieren jemanden der
sagt dass 80 prozent der priester im
vatikan schwul sei da frage ich mich wer
hier die augen vor der realität
verschließen
zunächst einmal habe ich tatsächlich nie
gesagt dass 80 prozent der priester im
vatikan schwul sein
danke dass sie das präzisieren ja ich
mache aber keine quantitative forschung
das wäre unmöglich selbst wenn sie alle
priester im vatikan interviewen würden
sollten ihnen nicht alle die wahrheit
erzählen was ich also tue ist
quantitativ entschuldigen sie bitte ich
mache qualitative forschung nicht
quantitative aber noch einmal es geht
nicht um die zahlen und das ziel ist
nicht zu verstehen ob dir christa der
dfb oder der kadima ziel schwul ist oder
nicht
und ich versuche nicht menschen zu outen
ich versuche das system zu verstehen
denn es hat manch faltige konsequenzen
besonders in bezug auf sexuellen
missbrauch darauf kommen wir sicher noch
zu sprechen
der hauptpunkt ist dass es um ein
soziologisches system geht wenn sie in
einem kleinen dorf in italien in den
1950 er jahren aufwachsen und sie
homosexuell sind oder sich nicht sicher
sind was genau sie sind sie fühlen sich
von frauen sexuell nicht angezogen und
sie wollen nicht heiraten
dasselbe gilt aber auch wenn man in
einer bürgerlichen familie in mailand
paris oder zürich hineingeboren wird und
bemerkt dass man sich nicht zu frauen
hingezogen fühlt sie haben also ein
problem und die lösung ist sie werden
priester
denn sobald sie ins seminar eintreten
müssen sie sich die witze nicht mehr
anhören die man über sie reist sie
können sich den gesamten geben und sie
können weiblichere kleidung tragen lange
röcke zum beispiel und ihre mutter die
sie am besten kennt sie wird ihren
entscheid verstehen und mittragen
denn sie ist glücklich über ihre
berufung priester werden zu wollen und
ihre schwächere zu einer stärke sie
leben ausschließlich unter männern
sie können mit der stimme singen mit ihr
sie wollen sie können die kleidung
anziehen die sie wollen
und das wichtigste sie müssen weder
heiraten noch beziehungen mit frauen
eingehen mit ihnen sie gar keine
beziehung wollen
[Musik]
geht nicht darum diesen männern
vorzuhalten dass lügen oder illegale
dinge tun
sie äußern sich nur auf die einzige
weise die gesellschaftlich akzeptiert
ist und die kirche hat die tatsache dass
eine große mehrheit der priester schwul
ist gefordert und bis zu einem gewissen
grad akzeptiert die verstehe argument
aber dieser mechanismus den sie
beschreiben das heißt 50 jahre her
wie ist es heute und wenn es so
offensichtlich ist wie sie sagen
denn sie haben ja gerade gesagt die
kirche akzeptiere es irgendwie also wenn
es so offensichtlich ist warum hat noch
nie jemand ein solches buch geschrieben
doch sehr verwunderlich ok ich möchte
zwei punkte diskutieren
zunächst zur ersten frage die sie
gestellt haben heute ist es anders das
ist ganz klar wer als heterosexueller
mann in ein priesterseminar eintritt
akzeptiert diese homoerotische
atmosphäre nicht mehr so wurde es mir
erzählt denn ich habe viele interviews
geführt
auch für schwule und das ist der zweite
punkt ist es heute anders
selbst in einem kleinen dorf in italien
oder auch in die schweiz muss man sich
heute nicht mehr verstecken man hat alle
möglichkeiten sexuell aktiv zu sein
niemand will heutzutage mehr priester
werden das ist eine tatsache und in
gewisser weise ist es eine quantitative
faktoren die situation in frankreich und
ich kenne nur die ist so rund 800
priester sterben jedes jahr
und bloß 60 werden ordiniert in zehn
jahren gibt es hierzulande also
praktisch keine priester mehr
heterosexuelle männer wollen nicht weil
sie nicht heiraten dürfen und die
homosexuellen haben andere möglichkeiten
nun sie fragten warum niemand ein
solches buch geschrieben hat
vor zehn jahren wäre es vermutlich noch
zu früh gewesen solche dinge zu
publizieren
so sagen die sachlage hat sich verändert
weil es heute mehr rechte für
homosexuelle gibt zb
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe und kann auch
das habe ihnen beim schreiben dieses
buches geholfen
in gewisser weise ja und dann gibt es
unglaubliche skandale wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs innerhalb der kirche diese
skandale betreffen tausende von
priestern in australien in den usa in
irland aber auch in brasilien und mexiko
oder ziele die wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs angeklagt oder verurteilt
und manche auch ins gefängnis gesteckt
wurden
dass priester keine sexualität haben
sollen glaubt heute niemand mehr
es geht um tausende von priestern
schauen von außen auf die römisch
katholische kirche
ich frage mich nun welche reaktionen sie
mit ihrem buch im inneren der kirche
ausgelöst haben so dumm wurde vor einem
jahr publiziert ist es also genug zeit
vergangen um auf ihre thesen zu
reagieren
ich habe auch die schweizer
bischofskonferenz gefragt was sie von
ihrem buch halten würden leider habe ich
keine antwort erhalten
sie sagt mir das im moment mit dem
chorus beschäftigt sein
falls mich interessiert ist welche
reaktion sie aus dem vatikan erhalten
haben und zwar von den leuten mit denen
sie nicht gesprochen haben
warum wurde ein derartiges buch noch
nicht veröffentlicht wählen sie
italienischer journalist sind und einen
italienischen verleger suchen werden sie
mühe haben weil es in diesem land nach
wie vor schwierig ist ein solches
bericht zu veröffentlichen wenn sie
vatikan ist sind also ein journalist die
vor allem über den vatikan schreibt dann
verlieren sie ihren job wenn sie ein
derartiges buch vorlegen
und wenn sie heterosexuell sind dann
kennen sie die codes der homosexuellen
community nicht
deshalb wurde dieses buch nicht vor 10
jahren sondern erst heute geschrieben
von einem franzosen der den code
beherrscht und kein vatikan ist ist aber
um ihre frage zu beantworten
die reaktionen waren sie unterschiedlich
zunächst einmal hat niemand kein
kardinal im grunde genommen ihr das buch
gesprochen und sie haben uns auch nicht
angegriffen oder gegen uns geklagt das
buch wurde also überall veröffentlicht
ohne dass es juristische konsequenzen
gegeben hätte aber weshalb haben sie
wohl nicht reagiert weil sie dachten das
buch sei ganz einfach unrichtig für sie
oder weil sich nicht dachten alles hier
drin sei blödsinn was mich sehr wundert
ist warum es keine reaktion darauf gab
wenn es doch dermaßen explizit ist ja
sie haben recht
und übrigens haben wir uns auch
abgesichert
14 juristen haben mich während des
schreibens begleitet wir wussten was wir
taten das buch wurde von sehr großen
mainstream verlagen in deutschland
frankreich italien und den usa
veröffentlicht den berühmtesten verlagen
überhaupt wollten diese geschichte haben
ja klar aber es ist ein seriöses buch
bloomsbury hat auch harry potter
veröffentlicht es sind keine erfundenen
geschichten
das meinte ich damit auch nicht
der vatikan ist also der journalist ist
fast nur mit dem vatikan befasst und der
kardinal den ich immer wieder
interviewte ich habe mit mehr als 40 mit
43 kardinälen genaugenommen gesprochen
sie alle haben mir die geschichte bis zu
einem gewissen grad erzählt jeder kennt
diese geschichte und wir können
natürlich über diesen einen spezifischen
punkt auf der seite xy diskutieren
denn es ist extrem schwierig über
sexualität und besonders über
homosexualität im vatikan zu arbeiten
wir können über einzelne punkte
diskutieren aber die gesamte theorie
wird sich dadurch nicht ändern da bin
ich hundertprozentig überzeugt
viele berühmte theologen sogar der papst
sagte in einer nichtoffiziellen
diskussion mit einem juristen die über
alle in lateinamerika und den usa
publiziert wurde
ich habe das buch gelesen es ist in
ordnung ich wusste alles das sagte papst
franziskus heute ist es so dass ich
nicht mehr oft mit leuten im vatikan
diskutieren
aber das ist normal nach dem man ein
solches buch veröffentlicht hat
sie haben sich keine freunde gemacht und
doch doch den kardinal sehe ich immer
noch auch den erzbischof und einige
priester die mich in den vatikan
eingeladen mit denen treffe ich mich
immer noch zum mittagessen in rom in
kleinen unauffälligen restaurants die
sind mir immer noch zugewandt aber es
stimmt dass die leute es vorziehen das
thema nicht zu diskutieren
weil das buch im grunde eines der
wichtigsten geheimnisse der letzten 40
jahre öffentlich gemacht hat aber ihre
behauptungen basieren jan er natürlich
auf privaten gesprächen wie können sie
sicher sein dass die leute mit denen sie
darüber gesprochen haben auch die
wahrheit sagen es tut mir leid das
erwähnen zu müssen aber so arbeiten
journalisten mir jemand sagt kardinal xy
sei schwul dann publiziere ich das nicht
wenn ich das getan hätte hätte der
vatikan sie auch niemanden
ich versuche zu erklären wie das system
funktioniert ich versuche nicht zu
urteilen und ständig gegen niemanden
einige wenige erwähne ich namentlich
aber nur wenn es bekannt ist dass sie
schwul sind weil das durch die medien
ging oder sie vor gericht standen oder
schon tot sind
doch lebende bischöfe und kardinäle f
eine ich nicht namentlich warum mein
ziel ist es nicht jemanden zu orten
sondern das system transparent zu machen
wenn sie so wollen den vatikan zu orten
und wichtig zu wissen ist die leute mit
denen ich sprach wussten wer ich bin ich
sagte immer meinen namen sie wissen dass
ich journalist und autor bin und dass
ich ein buch über den vatikan schreibe
aber nicht was am ende alles drin sein
wird wenn sie mich warten ihren namen
nicht zu verwenden habe ich das
respektiert off the record heißt of
direct die von mir angewandten regeln
sind die regeln des journalismus
internationaler zeitungen
lassen sie uns nochmals zum papst
zurückgehen sie erwähnten dass der papst
wisse was dem vatikan vor sich gehe
sie führen ihrem buch auch immer wieder
die angebliche doppelmoral der
katholischen kirche in mehreren predigen
von 2016 bis 2018 verurteilt
genau diese doppelmoral ziemlich
deutlich
[Musik]
sie glauben also dass papst franziskus
über alles bescheid weiß und dies schon
vor der publikation ihres buches bevor
sie wissen dass ich kein zauberer
und ich bin auch nicht jemand der
einfach so eine hypothese aufstellt wenn
ich sachverhalte erwähne dann nur weil
sie nie erzählt worden
ich habe enge berater von papst
franziskus getroffen
natürlich werden sie in meinem buch
nicht namentlich erwähnt weil sie anonym
bleiben wollten sie alle haben mir
erklärt wie das system im vatikan
funktioniert und wenn man papst
franziskus zuhört dann realisiert man
auch welche art von setzen er benutzt um
auf die probleme aufmerksam zu machen
und es gibt eine menge probleme im
vatikan
das problem mit der sexualität
homosexualität es nur ein aspekt davon
es gibt auch eine menge heterosexuelle
männer die sex mit frauen haben oder
haben möchten
es gibt ein problem mit geld und dann
gibt es das problem der macht und den
damit verbundenen machtmissbrauch und
dann gibt es den sexuellen missbrauch
der etwas komplett anderes ist als die
normale sexualität und so weiter und so
fort
sie und ihre zuschauer interessieren
sich für religion
sie müssen ein buch nicht lesen und mir
weder glauben noch mehr vertrauen aber
wenn sie das system nicht verstehen
werden sie beim nächsten skandal wieder
schockiert sein und verzweifelt es wird
neue skandale geben neue entschuldung an
einen neuen kardinal die geortet wird
eine unendliche geschichte
und ja der papst weiß es lassen sie
nicht noch eine frage stellen wenn ich
mehr darüber wissen möchte sie nennen
homosexualität als schlüssel zum
verständnis des vatikans sie haben das
jetzt bereits angesprochen aber könnten
sie es noch nie an leuten in welchem
sinn geht es denn einer verbindung
zwischen homosexualität und serbien in
ihrem buch ja auch wikileaks inwiefern
gibt es eine beziehung zwischen
homosexualität und dem vatikanischen
finanzskandal punkt ist homosexualität
und ich bin ziemlich breit gefächert in
der betrachtung dieses themas und
diskutiere beispielsweise auch wie das
mit der extremen rechten
in verbindung steht und auch viele
weitere aspekte des vatikans aber ja ich
denke homosexualität ist ein schlüssel
zur erklärung
ich möchte nochmals betonen dass ich
kein problem habe damit wenn ein bischof
oder ein kardinal schwul sind wenn die
einen liebhaber haben wenn sie sex haben
dann ist mir das egal wenn es nach mir
ginge dann wäre das erlaubt das einzige
problem ist wenn sie sex mit
minderjährigen haben oder wenn es um
prostitution geht oder wenn es um
missbrauch geht das heißt ohne
zustimmung des sexualpartners im vatikan
existiert noch ein 3d krise im
französischen sagen dieses recht gab es
in frankreich früher tatsächlich und es
besteht darin dass ein älterer der macht
ausübt also in diesem fall
beispielsweise ein bischof oder ein
lucius einen seminaristen oder jüngeren
priester um einen sexuellen gefallen
bitten darf
um ehrlich zu sein habe ich lieber einen
priester oder bischof mit einem freund
als einen priester der ein zehnjähriges
kind anfassten das ist alles natürlich
aber meine frage war in welchem sinne
diese themen miteinander verflochten
sind sie sagen nämlich dass es sich bei
homosexualität um einen schlüsselfaktor
handel
wenn es um die breit bekannten und
diskutierten skandale der römisch
katholischen kirche gehe damit den
missbrauchsskandal in ihren augen auch
als schwulen skandal zu verstehen oder
wir müssen wir uns das vorstellen und
auch differenzieren damit homosexualität
und pädophilie nicht vermischt werden
denn das wäre ja gefährlich
diese frage ist sehr gut und sie haben
recht
das problem ist die kultur der
geheimhaltung
wenn man ein system und eine
organisation hat die auf einer lüge
basiert und das ist der vatikan ja
tatsächlich
sie stimmen hier vielleicht nicht zu und
sie mögen mich nicht dafür dass ich das
sage aber das system vatikan besteht aus
lügen
juli geben wird über alles über geld
über die organisation an sich über macht
über sexualität wie auch immer diese
geartet ist in einer solchen kultur von
geheimhaltung und lüge ist es kein
problem leute zu haben die eine
sexualität ausleben die total verboten
ist weil sie durch die kultur der lüge
geschützt werden
und ich denke das ist das problem
das problem ist nicht die homosexualität
wie viele studien gezeigt haben gibt es
keine verbindung zwischen homosexualität
und sexuellem missbrauch
der größte teil sexuellen missbrauchs
wird innerhalb der familie begangen oder
in schulen
die opfer sind in der mehrheit mädchen
die täter also heterosexuelle genau
missbrauch ist hauptsächlich ein
heterosexuelles problem überall auf
direkt aber aus studien wissen wir auch
dass die opfer sexuellen missbrauchs in
der kirche zwischen 80 und 85 prozent
jungen oder junge männer sind
es gibt also eine besonderheit in der
katholischen kirche es gibt eine
verbindung zwischen klerikern die sich
für jungen und sehr junge männer
interessieren und sexuellem missbrauch
warum ist das das problem ist nicht die
homosexualität an sich das problem ist
dass man sein verlangen ob homosexuell
oder nicht unterdrückt sie tun das
gegenüber anderen aber auch gegenüber
sich selbst wenn sie derart unterdrückt
werden und eine strategie entwickeln um
ihre identität zu verbergen und sich
selber verleugnen müssen was tun sie
dann wenn sie sex haben wollen sie gehen
zu kindern
sie gehen zu immigranten oder zur neu
eingetretenen jungen im priesterseminar
weil sie die ihnen gegenüber autorität
haben und weil sie wissen dass die
nichts ausplaudern werden sie versuchen
sex mit menschen zu haben die nicht
sprechen werden
natürlich geht man nicht in einer
schwulenbar und sagt hey ich bin
kardinal ich bin bischof und ich möchte
dich kennenlernen
man muss eine strategie der vertuschung
entwickeln
und das ist der grund warum das system
als ganzes ein system ist das den
sexuellen missbrauch schützt obwohl und
darauf bestehe ich obwohl das ziel des
papstes oder des bischofs oder des
kardinals natürlich nicht der schutz des
sexuellen missbrauchs ist aber das
fehlverhalten wird eben trotzdem
geschützt weil die gesamt lügen nicht
diskutiert werden kann
aber wird sich das problem damit nicht
in ein paar jahrzehnten von selbst zumal
die gesellschaft immer liberaler wird
und auch homosexuelle immer mehr rechte
haben
ja und das ist auch das große problem
vor einem halben jahrhundert also 1968
in den 70er jahren war die kirche gegen
homosexuelle aber die gesellschaft als
ganzes war auch gegen schwule und lesben
homosexualität wurde nicht toleriert und
war in manchen ländern gar verboten
die haltung der kirche unterschied sich
also im grunde genommen nicht von jener
der gesellschaft das problem
manifestierte sich erstmals in den 1990
er jahren als die gesellschaft schwulen
freundlicher wurde die kirche musste
also darauf reagieren und wurde noch
homophobe als sie es schon war damit sie
ihr lügengebilde schützen konnte es geht
immer um ein sehr komplexes system
denn alle die priester des sexuellen
missbrauchs für schuldig gefunden wurden
waren homosexuell und es geht um geld
ich spreche von maxi almasi allen mexiko
kadima in chile wo er in österreich oder
mac eric in den usa und es geht auch um
ideologie viele der pädophilen priester
standen politisch sehr rechts
es waren bischöfe oder priester die den
vatikan viel geld spendeten aber auch
gegen die befreiungstheologie und gegen
den kommunismus in lateinamerika
kämpften und deshalb von johannes bau
den zweiten und sogar von papst benedikt
den sechzehnten geschützt worden
es tut mir schrecklich leid sie hierbei
unterbreche aber ich frage mich ob sie
mit diesem buch in der art wie sie es
geschrieben haben das heißt mit einigen
schadenfrohen details und allem was dazu
gehört ob sie mit diesem buch wirklich
die gläubigen erreichen was in diesem
fall jetzt zentral wäre sie sind ja
selber nicht gläubig sie schreiben dass
sie mir an literatur als eine
religiöse sklaven wäre es aber nicht
wichtig die gläubigen zu erreichen oder
war das gar nicht ihr ziel
wissen sie ich bekomme jeden tag zehn
briefe hauptsächlich von priestern
seinen katholischen gläubigen von
ehemaligen priester
sie schreiben mir dass sie schockiert
sind dass sie erst jetzt entdecken dass
das was sie erlebt haben einem system
entspringt genau dies war mein eindruck
oder das ist der grund warum ich nicht
mehr priester sein wollte oder ich wurde
auch missbraucht ich will nicht werbung
für mich selbst machen aber das buch war
in frankreich ein bestseller aus 15
ländern genau
wir haben weltweit wahrscheinlich mehr
als 600.000 exemplare verkauft ganz
genau wissen wir es nicht
die reaktion wenn sie so wollen waren
die leute die das buch gekauft und
gelesen hat auf französisch sagen wir
baske konzern weil sie es betrifft
es geht um ihr leben ich bin
schriftsteller und journalist
ich bin kein katholik ich bin schwul
ja ich war bis zum alter von zehn jahren
katholisch wie alle in frankreich aber
ich bin kultur katholik ich meine ich
bin im katholizismus aufgewachsen wie
jeder in diesem land und ich bin stolz
drauf
ich mag rambo ich mag berlin ich mag
rembrandt und leonardo da vinci und
michelangelo
das waren alles auch katholiken ich bin
lgbt freundlich und ich bin offen schwul
aber ich bin auch ein regisseur
ich denke dass ich seriös arbeite und
dinge zugänglich mache die ich für
nützlich hat aber ich bin kein richter
ich will die kirche nicht verändern denn
das ist nicht meine aufgabe
meine aufgabe ist es ein system zu
erklären
und zu beschreiben und dann können die
menschen handeln wenn sie wollen aber
das ist nicht meine aufgabe ich habe
keine politische agenda trotzdem wurden
sie beschuldigt ihre forschung mit ihren
persönlichen aktivismus für die rechte
der schwulen zu verletzen
das war ein punkt den man ihnen als
problem format ja aber das stimmt nicht
dasselbe könnte man auch über solche
lizenz sagen oder über und regie und den
kommunismus will mich kennt weiß dass
ich viel über meine eigenen leute
geschrieben habe ich war ein harter
kritiker der schwulen gemeinschaft
besonders während der aids epidemie
ich habe mehrere bücher geschrieben die
die leute der gay community sehr
kritisch sehen
von den katholiken erwarte ich dasselbe
ich erwarte dass sie ihre leute genauso
kritisieren wenn sie mein buch gelesen
haben vor allem den letzten teil dann
kann niemand behaupten ich hätte etwas
gegen katholiken oder gegen priester
nein das meinte ich aber auch nicht
genau
wenn sie ein solches buch schreiben dann
müssen sie drei dinge wissen
erstens wird man angegriffen zweitens
kann man nicht alles sagen was man weiß
und drittens kann man nicht alles
verstehen weil diese welt der vatikan so
verrückt und verblüffend ist dies bündig
zu alles ist durchdrungen von falschen
nachrichten und lügen und unwahrheiten
deshalb ist es so schwer den vatikan zu
verstehen und die meisten liegen habe
ich sowieso ausgelassen
die schreibe zum beispiel weder über den
tod von papst johannes paul im ersten
oder über die ermordung eines schweizer
gardisten darüber wurde so viel
spekuliert und geschrieben
ich kann nur über etwas schreiben wenn
ich hundertprozentig sicher bin und das
buch basiert nicht auf gerüchten oder
andeutungen sondern nur auf fakten auf
akten aus dem polizeiauto auf der
website zum buch gibt es zusätzlich über
300 seiten mit
dokumente und zeugenaussagen und danke
danke ihnen wurde die klarstellung
man kann dies alles auf ihrer homepage
nachzuschlagen unsere zeit ist leider
bereits um es tut mir sehr leid
weiterhin alles gute vielen dank auch
[Musik]